das ist okay ich entertainer ich jetzt
gehört nicht was ich sage
höchstwahrscheinlich aber in der
nachbearbeitung von daher hallo ich
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge von
minecraft fries mit dabei wies der liebe
ist um würfel der schild dahin noch
bisschen weil der cook hat nach twitter
themen weil ich zum würfel nimmt nicht
mit auf sondern das mache ich weiter
alleine weil ich wie schon in der
letzten folge angedeutet vor produziere
damit ihr folgen habt wenn ich in
alsfeld es kaputt gegangen ist alles
super wird da geht einiges starken
einiges da ist sollte direkt anfangen
möchte eine gute frage
machen sie sich machen der gute frage
eine weihnachtliche frage oder oder eine
interessante frage die ich das so gar
nicht mehr beantworten kann ist wie
lange kennen wir uns schon mathematisch
ich weiß es nicht
berlin wir haben uns nie kennengelernt
das weiß ich auch nicht er wollte morgen
mutter dem hersteller nämlich schon mal
angucken entstand nämlich da wir beide
uns kennengelernt haben und ich habe
überhaupt keine ahnung wer also erst
nicht
ich wüsste es jetzt auch nicht alter
etwa erst du dich eigentlich wer bist du
wer bist du eigentlich alle dafür macht
leider werde ich weiß dass er heute
tatsächlich überhaupt nicht mehr
hierbei kann nur eine gute frage
beides ist durch die beste frage lautet
wie man lieber der frage so viel
nachgedacht aber das frage ich mich bei
allem youtube wie ich mit denen
außerhalb marquez wir haben ja bei max
ja nee das weiß ich auch noch das war
auch durch ich irgendwann durch galaxy
war das okay weil ich ja gar nicht wo
ich glaube bei uns war das aber fast
auch so oder also dass wir zumindest das
erstmals aufgenommen hat weiters sind
gerne hier los das war mit ich glaube
zweite oder dritte folge nee das war
aber auch schon vor galaxy weil wir
wollten ja auch in einem team zusammen
wir wollten in ein team
jetzt gab doch diese delta und alpha
dingen bei und da haben wir doch schon
ohne makel dass wir zusammen in eine
fraktionen möchten was nicht
funktioniert hat also kann man uns
vorher auch schon aber ich weiß auch
nicht ich weiß aber auch tatsächlich
mehr warum
oder wie oder ich weiß ja überhaupt
nicht mehr wie wir überhaupt irgendwie
kontakt gekommen sind
mit dem meisten ist halt so dass man das
über die zeit und hält man sich und
irgendwie und dann blau dann kommt das
irgendwie aber jetzt so nee also keine
ahnung jetzt genau wüsste ich auch nicht
vielleicht ist das ja noch was ist unser
erstes video irgendwie zusammen
das ist halt richtig traurig dass es
endlich wissen wie unsere
liebesbeziehung angefangen hat als
update hier was ich gerade mache ich
mache hier gerade
einfach den ganz kleinen hütte und dem
euch einfach mal zu weil den braucht man
nicht weiter immer weiter
und hier ja ich weiß gar nicht wie ich
das jetzt hier richtig bauen soll
das ist schwer wird brachte sturm massiv
zu erstehen den guten überblick im
nennen architektur
ich glaube ich war richtig viel schnee
für das euch vorab kokain kürzlich noch
schnee ich habe keinen schimmer
du hast glaub ich richtig viel von allen
sachen die ich benötige aber du willst
einfach nicht geben
die weltbestenliste eine kiste möchte
ich gar nicht mehr raus
ich habe keine kisten brauchst du dir
dann hab ich dir nicht dankeschön von
schimpfworten
ich hole jetzt einfach richtig viel
schnee für den gang den ich hier vorab
und dann würde ich sagen hast vielleicht
schon eine zweite frau ist die wahre
übel verantworten
geht doch einfach nicht aber schaffen
wir vielleicht zuschauer lena fragt
dennoch hat er schon mit dem weihnachts
einkäufen bekommen oder seid ihr auch so
spät dran ich weiß gleich also mein
kumpel wenn man so ein bisschen
wir wollten unseren kaffee gehen hier in
hamburg und danach wollten wir auf jeden
fall so ein paar geschenke einkaufen
fall
ich habe letztens die seite fans für
mich entdeckt kennst du die fans ihn
muss man drauf gehen fans i.com bass
glaube ich oder fancy googeln da gibts
halt richtig viele gadgets irgendwie
so ein handy hülle wo auch wir öffneten
flaschenöffner dran ist so was in die
richtung und das habe ich halt gedacht
okay was passt kann ich meinen eltern
schenken weil die sagen immer soja der
handy hüllen mit dürfen wir die sagen so
ja wir wünschen uns nicht merkwürdig so
sag doch was ihr wollt so weil man ihn
holen soll
dann denke ich mir okay mit plateau lich
denen die später als rächer sondern hab
ich mir gedacht okay ich schon mal bei
ccp angemeldet übrigens ich weiß nicht
ob man einen erfolgen kann oder
irgendwie so aber ich heiße laser luca
also fancy kommen die dort laserdrucker
so heißt ihr auf jeden fall werde ich
jeder schaut sich also deshalb wie
instagram da werden so sachen auch gern
von welchen design an
die sagen dann guck mal hier das ist
mein zum beispiel letztens waren da so
lichter die wasserfest sind die katze in
den offenen pool stellen oder in der
badewanne oder so da hab ich mir gedacht
ok kommen fans die sache oder sohn manny
clip einfach sein portemonnaie ganz
klein
da das gewicht ist brauchst du natürlich
doppelklick mitteldorf machen und das
gefällt heißt es und das ist so wie
leighton auf instagram und da habe ich
einfach mal nachgeschaut und geschaut
was ich da kaufen kann und darf ich
richtig viele coole sachen gefunden zb
für meine mutter ich hoffe sie schaut
sich das video mit ihr habe ich da gab
es eine toto storage box heißt die keine
vielleicht auch mal google die habe ich
jetzt bestellt mit amazon prime die
sollte jetzt eigentlich morgen da sein
da ist ein das ist einfach sondern
kleine kiste sondern holzkiste ist aber
ganz cool die seite da kann man
einerseits viele fächer darin kann man
halt anders irgendwie fällt so schminkt
sachen reinstecken gesonnen pinsel nicht
zum pinsel
wer kennt sie nicht die weihnachtsinsel
wenn du denn denn diese vision dieses
schicksal pasanen lippenstift rouge
kacke die anfangs sie nicht ins gesicht
pflanzen kommt das ist eine spitzen
storage box hat irgendwie weiß nicht 20
oder so kostet das weihnachtsgeschenk
für die familie gedachte kirche
ausgestellt
verglichen mit den preisen fisch stürmer
für eine stunde genau das ist bitter
gegen also zwei euro fünfzig 67
starterfeld ist übrigens ein echter
handynummer deswegen habe ich mich
gefragt warum wir den preis gibt einfach
hier
ich will dass die leute mich anrufen ich
mache auf rang drei noch drei schaufeln
und dann gehe ich einfach mal schnee
wollen einfach mal kurz ich habe
übrigens noch keine geschenke frage ganz
simple beantworteten nicht so
ausführlich wie luca einfach nur damit
wir zur nächsten exciting frage welches
weihnachtsgebäck möglich am liebsten
oder welches geht die han nicht fragt
isabel er dieser welt beantworten um als
ersetzt ich mag ja total gerne plätzchen
wenn ihr ein totaler plätzchen
fetischist problem ist nur keiner in
meiner familie mag oder macht neben
macht keine also bei uns gibts echt
super seiten yazoo weihnachtliches essen
ich meine wir haben glaube ich so viele
essens folgen jetzt ins schon gehabt
wäre schon mehrfach gesagt dass wir
immer an weihnachten eigentlich die die
fleischfresser familie sinn für humor
ist bei uns aber auch so also immer
kleiner fisch
aber immer wenn wenn dann plötzlich ganz
klar wieso weihnachtsplätzchen
ja ich finde auch ich würde auch sagen
plätzchen irgendwie weil ich bin nicht
so der mega ich könnte es mir nicht so
zehn tafeln schokolade untereinander
reinziehen
aber plötzlich muss ich sagen dass
spekulationen wie sowas in der richtung
das ist auf jeden fall auch mein ding an
weihnachtsgebäck oder jürgen erzählt auf
jeden fall im gepäck also von gebäck
echt plätze mal sowas wie vor dass ich
sofort mit aso aus
das mädchen richtig süßes platz
bestätigt gern 2 platz bei mir klingelt
welche holen klingelt denn jetzt bei mir
hat mal wieder zu früh
vor allem die tatsache okay ich
entertainer euch jetzt gehört nicht was
ich sage
höchstwahrscheinlich aber in der
nachbearbeitung von daher hallo hallo
nachbearbeitung sluka wenn du das hier
höchst möchte ich dir kurz sagen dass
ich jetzt auf dem weg zu kippen hallo
finde dich okay
hey mein kumpel ist derzeit noch eben
schnell die letzten zwei drei minuten
gleich einkaufen
pünktlich auf die sekunde genau menschen
ich wollte eigentlich den gang noch
fertig bauen aber das macht dann in der
nächsten folge und zwar nicht mehr zeit
nicht noch ein bisschen schnee mit dass
wenn ihr euch fragt hier im winter so
viel schnee mit einfach nur um den
ganzen schnee anstatt wenn ich den
gartenbau war ich glaub mit schnee sieht
am besten aus so weihnachts mäßig die
nächsten zwei folgen werden
alleine gemacht oder mit mit irgendwem
anders oder so könnt ihr mal die
kommentare schreiben mit wem ihr das
wollt und danach werde ich die letzte
folge am 24 ihr zufolge für mich vom
projekt werde ich mit staffel hochladen
und einfach damit er dann sagen kann was
bei denen das bei dem was anderes abgeht
oder keine ahnung was weil ich halt
einfach vorproduzieren hab ich ja schon
gesagt jetzt hoffe ich noch eben schnell
rasch zurück in die heimat statt da
hinten und dann würde ich sagen wir sind
zwar heute nur auf drei fragen
eingegangen
aber die erste frage wäre echt
interessant wenn wir uns das mal
schreiben können welche überhaupt keinen
plan habe warten wir es kennen
das hat auch richtig schwule bi oder wie
wann oder wie ja wir haben leute können
ja nicht wissen glauben herren sagen
aber er war ja klar internet live oder
so
diese folge gefallen hat die bewertung
wir sehen uns dann in folge wieder